this episode is brought to you by mac
weldon
mag weldon is reinventing men's basics
they believe in smart design premium
fabrics
and simple shopping i've been smashing
and testing
the hell out of a bunch of their stuff
and i'm gonna focus on their underwear
as one example
i've been wearing their air knit x five
inch boxer briefs
for a while now and i absolutely love
them i've used them to hike
in national parks like big bend i use
them to record podcasts
they can be used for anything they're
engineered to keep you dry cool and
comfortable
to the end of your workout or work day
the fabric is soft
lightweight microfiber which maximizes
airflow and stretches in every direction
it's breathable
moisture wicking and odor fighting which
is great for a bridge troll
like me here's what a few critics have
to say new york times slash
wire cutter evaluated mack weldon's
18-hour jersey
boxer brief here we go quote our testers
seemed almost conflicted about how fancy
they felt while wearing these boxer
briefs
quote these are lovely you put them on
and you feel rich one tester said
this underwear makes me want to waste
money on a hotel room and fancy boost to
seduce my already wife and spoil her
right added another
now to esquire quote an expertly
executed pair of briefs from a brand
that doesn't better than almost anyone
else
end quote now to men's health mac weldon
took the process seriously
with over 10 000 hours to perfect the
best underwear money can buy seriously
this one checks all the boxes you should
be looking for when purchasing underwear
end quote now back to me mac welding
also covers a lot more than
underwear they have socks shirts
underwear hoodies polos active shorts
they check all the boxes mack weldon
promises comfort and a consistent fit
for
all of your basics so check them out and
try them out if you don't like your
first pair of underwear you can actually
keep them and they will still refund you
no questions asked so you have nothing
to lose again my favorite
so far is probably the air knit x 5 inch
boxer briefs
it seems like the 18 hour jersey boxer
brief is one of the most popular
so check them out to get 20 off of your
first order
visit mackweldon.com tim tim and enter
promo code
timtim that's m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n.com
tim tim and use promo code tim tim
mack weldon reinventing men's basics
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device
called the pod pro cover by eight sleep
it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress and
start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature my girlfriend runs hot all
the time she doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing
now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users fall asleep up
to 32 percent faster
reduce sleep interruptions by up to 40
and get more restful sleep
overall i can personally attest to this
because i track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling refreshed and now my dear
listeners that's you guys
you can get 250 off of the pod pro cover
that's a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim
or use code tim that's eight all spelled
out
e-i-g-h-t sleep dot com
slash tim or use coupon code tim
t-i-m eight sleep dot com slash tim
for 250 off your pod pro cover
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode
of the tim ferriss show i'm thrilled to
have
our guest today juliana furci
on instagram at julie fungi that's
g-i-u-l-i-f-u-n-g-i
juliana is founder and executive
director of the fungi foundation
established in 2012 the world's first
non-profit dedicated solely
to fungi she is a harvard university
associate dame of the order of the star
of italy which is one of the best
honorary titles i've ever heard in my
life
co-chair of the iucn fungal conservation
committee
mother author of several titles
including a series of field guides to
chilean fungi
and contributor to numerous publications
on the environment such as the first
state of the world's fungi report
biodiversity
and the ibpa award-winning book
fantastic fungi
juliana has worked for the fungi since
1999 and in the nonprofit sector for the
last
17 years she has held consulting
positions in u.s philanthropic
foundations
as well as full-time positions in
international marine conservation ngos
in chilean environmental ngos you can
find her on instagram
at julie fungi again that's spelled
g-i-u-l-i fungi and at
fungi foundation the website is
fungi.org
juliana welcome to the show thank you
very much tim it's an honor and a
pleasure
i thought we would start at the
beginning because you
represent quite an international
cocktail
you're born in the uk of a chilean
mother and an italian father
how does that all come together how does
that happen
well the short and unsweet answer to
that
is that dictatorship and exile leads to
that
so my mother was a victim
of the coup in 1973 here in chile
she was a political prisoner for a year
incarcerated and tortured and then made
to leave
and she left chile arrived in italy
where she met my father and then
moved to london with a scholarship to
study a master's degree so i am a
product of exile
wow i have many follow-up questions
so we're going to work in reverse order
what did your mother
study for her masters my mother is a
geographer and an economist
so she has always studied things that
have to do with decentralization
why was she persecuted
under the regime after the coup in
chile because first of all she thought
differently
and that's one of the biggest sins in
these regimes
she was a student and she
from a very young age was active
in politics in student fora and
brilliant just creating discussion
when she fled or when she left how did
she choose where to go
no there's no choice she was
incarcerated
for 365 days and then given
two weeks to leave so that all boils
down to where
you can get to and she
jumped over to argentina jumped over the
andes she didn't jump or she flew over
to argentina
but argentina was also under really
unstable
political regimes various dictatorships
and from there she was able to
travel to italy where she stayed for two
years
and then to england so really there's no
choosing
now did italy come out of a contact
in argentina i'm just wondering why
italy specifically that country i know
that in places like buenos aires of
course you have
a very long history of immigration
from italy from spain from germany
is that how the country italy itself as
a destination came up
no it wasn't through argentina it was
because
her mother my grandmother and aunt
had already left chile and had
established in italy
the reason is italy was open to
receiving refugees
italy had a policy of welcoming
people who were fleeing the regime here
and so did other countries like sweden
you know and other places around the
world so it's more to do with how italy
was
open to receiving people how did
and this may not seem germane to
[Music]
much of what we'll explore later but it
is germane because it relates to
how you became who you are how did your
parents meet
father was a student in rome
i come from a very small village
in calabria my father's family my
grandparents
didn't know how to read or write they
were contadini
so producers of olive oil wine salami
subsistence living
and my father left his village
and went to study by day and work by
night
and was studying when you know the
italian
communist party and socialist party were
welcoming all these chilean refugees
and he met my mother during a welcome
party
for chilean refugees and they fell in
love
yeah and that was it and that was it
in your life you were
born in the uk how did you end up being
born in the uk
because my mother was offered this
scholarship to study
in london she left with my father and
that's where the magic happened in
council housing in north london
and for you then just geographically
because of course you're back in chile
now
no not back tim sorry i have we have to
say this so my mother came back
but i didn't come back here i was born
and i came
so we're another generation of uprooted
people i didn't come back how did you
end up then
where you are now i was born in england
right and grew up in england and when my
mother came back
i came with her but i never left
chile to come back here i was born out
outside during her exam that's right
fair enough fair enough
yeah so there's an untold story there of
many of the
offspring children of refugees and
exiles
who also have their life truncated in
some
paths because their parents can return
to their homeland and you come with them
because who are you to stop them from
you know coming back to where they never
chose to leave from how old were you
when you
not returned to but traveled to chile
almost 15.
what was that like going from the uk to
chile because i'm no cosmopolitan
connoisseur of all cultures but i happen
to have been to both countries they're
not identical
they are definitely not identical it was
a challenge but i was always
very conscious that
i was in no place to be an impediment
for my mother
to come back to the country she'd never
chose to leave
so i came in total humble
respect of making her return smooth
and was it smooth it wasn't smooth it
was very difficult
she came back to a country she didn't
recognize she came back
to parents that were old and in the case
of my grandfather
ill and she came back to a country
that was disjunct a country that was
looking for this sort of neo-capitalist
development way of doing politics and
commerce
but not quite getting there so it was
hard
and did you then study in chile or did
you study
and do your undergraduate and so on
elsewhere
i stayed in school here with very
difficult stories so
my mother had never told me that
there were people who liked the dictator
so i got to school here and people would
ask me you know
where are you from i'm from london and
why were you there well my mom was a
refugee
and i remember a classmate saying oh
your mother was a terrorist
you know she should have been killed and
having a go at me in the classroom and i
remember
running back home and saying to my
mother how did you not
warn me that there were people who liked
him
you know i had never ever in my life
encountered people
who liked the dictator so that was
challenging i i stuck in school and then
i went at the end of my
schooling and it was time to choose
undergraduate studies
all i knew is that i wanted to give back
in some way
i wanted to give back and at first i
thought that it was
through humans and i
i went to university to study social
working
and about a year into that i was really
really clear that
it wasn't humans humans weren't my thing
and so i then realized that it was
nature
it had to do with giving back in some
sort of way
and i thought okay let's get humans into
green spaces
right so i tried a second career and an
undergraduate career at landscaping and
ecology
and it was still so many humans it was
like planning
parts in perfect areas there were a lot
of homo sapiens involved
and i was like no this isn't it and
finally i said okay
i'm just gonna try plants in the water
like there will be no humans there
underwater and i studied aquaculture and
that's where i finished my undergraduate
studies in southern chile
in northern patagonia i went to a
university
in a city where i knew nobody and it was
i managed to finish it and it was on
that journey that i got to where i am
now
so how do you hop well let me ask first
is aquaculture
a vibrant and widespread endeavor
in chile because i have very little
familiarity i know for instance in new
zealand
it's a huge focal point but in chile i
would imagine with the coastline perhaps
that's also the case
unfortunately chile is a country
that has housed open net pen
salmon farming in its waters so
for your audience and our audience today
to understand aquaculture is basically
the cultivation
of aquatic resources aquatic species
so it could be algae can be shellfish
mollusks or fish fin fish and chile is
one of the largest producers of farmed
salmon
in the world salmon aren't native to the
southern hemisphere
and therefore the aquaculture industry
of
salmon in chile come with tremendous
environmental and social
impact but it means also that there is a
vibrant aquaculture industry
and so there were university careers and
i studied aquaculture and got into algae
seaweed farming and that was really what
i did my thesis on
and what i graduated doing and ended up
curiously working in ngos against
the salmon farming industry and its
negative impacts not against
the labor opportunities but against
their environmental practices you know i
should really
know this by now so i'm going usually i
blame it on my audience and i say for
those of my audience who may not know
could you define ngo
i've i've long thought that i've
understood what ngo means but perhaps
just to confirm that
could you or could you define what an
ngo is
ngo is the acronym for a non-mental
so a non-profit it's an organization
that represents
civil society and that has
a place at tables recognized as where
people organize and find a
voice that represents them so could you
give me an example
or maybe they are one in the same is it
fair to say that not all
non-profits are ngos but all ngos are
non-profits
or are there for-profit ngos no there is
never a for-profit ngo
ngos we measure our success
not in revenue of
money in the bank but of durable change
that's
our measure of success the change we can
make
so where did you go or how did you go
from
aquaculture to fungi how does that
happen
oh it's a funny one tim so i was in
university and i
remember one morning walking along the
corridors and
there was a poster stuck on the corridor
that said
volunteers needed to
look for fox poop in
forests and i was like oh that sounds
amazing
fox i really love scat and poop and we
can get into that afterwards like so
much grows out of it
um and so of course i
i volunteered and of course i was the
only one who volunteered and i ended up
getting
the volunteer position and traveling
with
my professor jaime jimenez who studies
foxes and other animals that's a great
name also
we traveled to chile island in southern
chile
and what we had to do was we had to put
these
big cages out to capture
non-violently but to capture and trap
the foxes we would put
radio transmitter colors on them and
then we would free them and walk around
the forest
collecting poop and also with a huge
antenna
trying to find a signal to triangulate
their position
using radio telemetry so this is really
old school technology today you would
just put like a gps chip on them
you know on a collar but this was you
know 20 something years ago and we're
walking around
bushwhacking with a huge antenna and
trying to get some sound in to see where
their position is
and at the same time picking up all the
poop we could find and then
i would go back to the laboratory and
dry the poop
and then sort of open it up and see what
they had eaten
that was my job but it was on that trip
that i was walking along a path with
this antenna
and i saw a huge mushroom on a tree
trunk
and i wanted to know who it was and
there were no books on chilean fungi
and it was a lightning bolt it was like
i'm gonna do this
and something happened that
i have never been able to stop even if
i've tried
but i got home and
online shopping had just begun and
barnes and noble
had the opportunity to ship books to the
us and then i'd have
somebody you know ship them to chile and
then amazon was a thing too and i
bought every book i could find on fungi
of course paul stamet's books were the
first ones i found
and i would devour everything i could
read
it was that one mushroom who i
wanted to know that the trick at all
i love that you use who with the fungi
i really really like that and
i must ask because i just need to know
it'll bother me if i don't
what was the objective of the research
with the
fox scat and radio telemetry we were
measuring
how the foxes were being displaced
due to logging of native forest
so as the forest was being lost habitats
destroyed where were the foxes going
um and they were going uphill up the
mountain trying to get into more and
more remote places but then
you know you get to the tree line and
there's not much more food for them so
we wanted to know what they were eating
as they were moving and there were a lot
of rodents they were eating
and a lot of really beautiful
beetle exoskeletons you find rainbows in
foxcat i have to say that
[Laughter]
sounds like an art opportunity for some
aspiring
graphic artist out there and
as you tell the story of seeing this
mushroom on the tree trunk
being unable to find a book that
covers the describes or catalogues
chilean fungi for me that begs the
question
in general why does it seem that
mushrooms and fungi have been so
understudied
there are two main reasons and the first
one is because
fungi have always been associated to the
pagan
to paganism right they're organisms that
are associated with
rot with decomposition they
often have textures and
odors that aren't pleasant to all
they grow associated to
humid and sometimes dark places
so that's one reason and and of course
their
fantastical properties at altering
states of consciousness
which for the catholic church was
something very
scary and very dangerous and on the
other hand
they were thought to be plants
and they were thought to be inferior
plants
which is even worse now they were
treated as
this group of organisms with moss
and with ferns that
were just very minorly important
with respect to vascular plants that
form trees and you know beautiful
flowers
and so they were discarded so you
mentioned paul
paul is a huge fan of yours as
uh we as we both know you have
certainly from that first encounter with
that mushroom on the tree
learned a lot and
i'd love to hear within chile
what you've found that strikes you as
as unique or interesting with respect to
mycology there are two ways to
to answer this question first of all my
journey is forged on the absence of
opportunity in chile
so when i discovered
fungi and discovered that i couldn't
really
find much more about them there was
nowhere to study here in chile
nowhere at all i had a choice my choice
was
i could leave chile and i could
go back to england i could study
mycology i could become a researcher
really really enrich my knowledge
or i could use my life's effort to make
sure that nobody else would ever
be faced with that decision again and
use my life's effort so that nobody
would ever
ever have to feel that he had to leave
their country if they loved
mycology and that was my choice and
that's where i found i could give back
so really what startled me about chile
first of all was the absence of
opportunity and the opportunity to
create opportunity
and in terms of the fungal diversity of
chile everything is fantastic
every encounter is sublime
the colors the textures the
possibility to walk in a forest in fall
and in an hour encounter over a hundred
different species different sizes
different
contextuals textures smells
different functions and ultimately this
opportunity
to coincide with these most amazing
organisms in the world yeah
have you discovered any new species
of fungi yes i have i've had the honor
and pleasure of coinciding for the first
time
as a human with a fungus i've named
two formerly one is
a very special fungus called amanita
galactica
it's it's an amanita that grows
in mixed monkey puzzle trees with
southern beach
so arogadia with another vegas and
it's a very very old species tim
it's an elder species it's a species
that was
around when the supercontinent gondwana
existed when the continent still hadn't
drifted apart
so we know that it's a species that
originates when that huge
landmass that created the southern
hemisphere was still stuck together
how do you know that in the sense that
unlike
say stuff like you could take a snuff
tray in atacama
and do carbon dating but with with fungi
that is not the tool that you would use
is it
looking at this is a term i only
recently learned the phylogeny
and somehow mapping it to
the span of humankind i would just love
to know
how humans have confidence that that is
the case
we've convened as humans that
we organize life
based on common ancestry so
we know for example that fungi are more
closely related to
animals than to plants because we have a
more recent
ancestor and curiously
this is a small parenthesis to what
we're talking about but that common
ancestor between fungi and animals
are the opistocons so it's a cell that
has a posterior flagellum
namely a sperm for example sperm
cell is an apistocont now there are some
fungi that have
that same type of cell there's one cell
with a posterior flagellum
so that's how we know that we're more
closely related because
both fungi and animals have that type of
cell that's like a sperm
now with amanita galactica we know
how old she is or he is because
the most recent common ancestor that we
have discovered
is extremely old so we build
relationships and
timing of these relationships based on
common ancestry and closest relation
what was the term you used for the
super continent
is that the same as pangaea or is
pangaea
no they're not the same so they're not
angier was one
big super continent that first
split into two laurasia
that then divided to form the northern
hemisphere and gondwana
that then divided on the southern
hemisphere
i see thank you yeah learning so much
i'm learning so much and i'm gonna dig
further so
with say amanita galactica you mentioned
he or she now is that just a personal
preference as to which
pronoun you choose or are fungi gendered
i don't know
they are not gendered but they're not
it's
either they're not objects so
if we're talking about an animal we
wouldn't
really call it an it right we're talking
about plants we wouldn't either
i honestly cannot and i'm very
uncomfortable with
objectifying any species of living
organism
i just can't call them it really
of course this is a very sensitive
subject in a lot of places now but in
in english this is where we fail
in a sense because we have to choose a
pronoun we could use they
of course but then you have something
like chinese where it's like the
pronunciation at least the writing is
different but
you have ta ta it's the same pronoun
regardless of who or what you're talking
about
effectively so it's it's a lot easier to
navigate how did you choose the name
and also i'm not familiar with many
i'm anita i'm only familiar with amanita
muscaria and pretty much everyone is
familiar
visually with that because it is
the most commonly depicted sort of red
cap with white dots
what does amanita galactica look like
and
how did you name it so amanita galactica
is a little smaller
than amanita muscaria which is the flyer
garrick and some people know it as you
know the smurf mushroom some people
cool the santa claus mushroom and to
close mushroom actually
soma amanita muscadia is the godsoma in
vedic cultures it's a very very
divine fungus and it's the oldest known
hallucigen to humanity
huge respect amanita muscaria amanita
galactica
has a black cap with white
scales and i can let you in on a funny
story people think that it's really
romantic
to find a new species i was actually in
the car
driving and of course you know one's eye
is pretty
used to catching that fungal fuzz you
know there's there's something there's a
vibe in fungi that's different from soil
it's different from plants
that visual vibe came through and i
stopped the car it was snowing it was
freezing cold
and i saw this black mushroom
cap with white dots and it was like
looking into a starry night
and i immediately said this is amanita
galactica
it was instant it was looking into the
galaxy
and i was in the car with two other
people and nobody would get out because
it was snowing and raining and
literally freezing and i was like oh i'm
getting out of course i'm getting out
and i spent quite a while with the
mushrooms there
and had the sense that it was something
new it was in an
old habitat and a very pristine habitat
and so yeah it was called manita
galactica and then the journey begins
of finding out somebody else has ever
coincided
and that's a long journey you know you
have to look at
records of people finding amanitas and
if they did what were those
underneath the you know what they look
like microscopically
you know what was their dna and over
time it became
evident that it was a species nobody had
ever coincided with before
so what is the protocol i'm just
imagining you're in
winter clothing you're driving along you
hop out
your friends are like oh god how long is
this going to take freezing our asses
off
exactly and uh i've been to portillo and
some places in chile and it gets
cold and
do you pluck the mushroom
the fruiting body and then go back to
the
lab and i'm not sure if it would be
spore prince or what the current
process processes how do you go about
determining if it is a new species
so the first thing to do i have a
particular method which is
i like to spend time with every species
i encounter so i get to their level
so i'm one of those you know people who
lie on the floor and
i will lie down i will first you have to
feel
tim because if you're going to describe
you
have to feel so there's a lot of
looking without touching there's a lot
of
smelling without touching observing
the surroundings who is it growing with
what trees are close because fungi are
specific to their substrate they never
grow and live separate from a symbiont
so what trees are around are there more
and then clearing begins clearing around
the mushroom observing what happens if i
touch it does it change does it change
in color
does it stain does it break there's a
lot of that there's a lot of very
detailed feeling with the senses of
touch
of seeing of smelling observing if you
know animals come out of it
or don't and we don't
pluck them we will when you're doing
scientific collecting you will try to
pop it out making sure that
nothing remains in the soil so you will
dig a bit with your fingers
and you will make sure you get to the
bottom of this sporum of this
macroscopic body
and pick it up observing every single
step because there are some
mushrooms that you touch and they change
color
that you touch and you lose a texture
that you pick up and it breaks and
whether it's hollow whether it's stuffed
whether it's solid really important
features
whether when you pick it up and it
starts going dry
it changes color is a really important
feature everything is important so
there's a lot of
sensuality in that first encounter
and then you carefully wrap it in
something that doesn't
scratch it or sometimes you can just
hold it in a basket
making a little bed and we go back to
if you're lucky you're in a place with
electricity i am a field mycologist that
explores
pristine areas of the world so sometimes
it's just going back to camp
we go back and another process of
observation begins
but now opening that mushroom up cutting
it
again what's inside is it solid inside
does it change does it smell it's really
a sensual process
and after you write down all these notes
you take photographs with
size references you proceed to dry it
now you have to dry it in a very
specific way
in which dna isn't degraded
now we can't cook them 80 90 percent of
a mushroom is water so it's a process
that's
really important otherwise it will rot
and
if you have electricity you'll use a
food dehydrator
now traditionally because i explore
pristine places for fungi and there's no
electricity the drying part is the
biggest
challenge and believe it or not nobody
has invented
a really efficient field dehydrator yet
so i put them in my sleeping bag
and i normally share a tent
with my fungi my collected fungi and
use body heat to dry them or silica gel
and then once they're stored dry you
look at the microscope for microscopic
features
and you extract dna for sequencing
now before it used to be the microscopic
features that would
determine the relationships between
species
today we know that those microscopic
characteristics aren't enough
to determine relatedness and we use dna
so based on those dna sequences and
databases that exist of all these
sequences you know whether it's been
discovered or not and then you proceed
to describe i see so you have
the equivalent of like an interpol dna
database
for a fungi
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the four
hour body this is more than 10 years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market it
has multi vitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i focus on nutrient-dense meals
to begin with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer on top of their all-in-one
formula
which is a free vitamin d supplement and
five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us
are deficient in vitamin d i found that
true for myself
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so adding a vitamin d
supplement to your daily routine is a
great option for additional immune
support support your immunity
gut health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your subscription
again that's athleticgreens.com
you drinking mate yes i am
so jealous
now do you call that straw okay for
people who can't see the visual
you're holding a gourd it has i don't
know if it's if it's covered in
carved leather no it's pumpkin carved
pumpkin
calabasa with with with some
ornamentation on the outside has it has
a metal top so it looks kind of like a
baseball
that has the very top cut off and then
it's hollowed out
you have yerba mate in there which looks
kind of like chopped spinach to the
untrained eye
which you then what is the word in
english steep cebar
right and then you have the straw do you
call that a bombilla
yes yeah so you stick a straw into this
and the straw has holes in it it's a
metal straw so the straw does the
filtering
that really brings back the memories i
used to live
in argentina so i drank mate
almost every day whether it was crust
maltamonte
oh you lived in argentina tim i did
don't hold it against me i won't i won't
but i'm really curious as to
why i was spending time
in panama in 2005.
i think it was 2005. might have been
2004
and i became friends with someone who is
half
panamanian and half argentine
in panama city and his family had been
there a very long time
living in panama and he had
spent a lot of time in argentina and i
had no plans for my next step
i was letting the wind carry me at the
time
and he said you need to visit argentina
i said why do i need to visit argentina
and he said
they have the best wine in the world
best steak in the world the most
beautiful women in the world and you can
live for pennies on the dollar and i
said well that's a
pretty good that's a pretty good pitch
and went to
argentina planning to be there for four
weeks
and i was
just dying one day in the middle of
summer
it was so humid and i was walking down
this pedestrian walkway
called avenida florida which is a
pertonal
and i'm walking down this pedestrian
walkway which is
like an arcade and like the santa monica
promenade for people who've ever been to
that
walking down and there was a tango shop
blaring music but i could feel the air
conditioning coming out of the tango
shop
and so i walked in and i'm just
loitering
i'm waiting for a friend to get out of a
class a spanish class
and ultimately the woman who was working
there this
chain smoking older woman was very upset
or she wasn't upset she was annoyed that
i was
clearly not going to buy anything and
she was like
hey bibe bibe is like kid
she said if you're gonna sit here you
might as well buy a ticket to a tango
class upstairs and so i did for tim i
think it was 10 pesos
and i became obsessed with tango and i
danced and stayed there for nine months
that's incredible yeah i ended up
competing
and doing all this stuff wow
so i have sorry it's great it's great so
i haven't
i haven't danced tango in probably 10
plus years but
that is what took me to argentina and i
drank mate all the time amazing
and i actually had something called
mate leo from brazil yeah
this morning which i had the instantized
mate but i was thinking to myself this
morning i'm like this just
isn't the same the instant matter is not
not the same
no i have to send you a mate i'm going
to the u.s next month
so i'm going to take it i'm going to
take
i promise here no it's amazing i gifted
pablo paul
yeah i miss one too i wonder if he uses
it i have to get back to that one
oh if he doesn't he could just mail me
his i no
no i'm not i'm spending ramata you have
to it's so good for your health
i love mate people people ask me all the
time we're getting off topic here but
you know what is your favorite
smart drug and i i the brains are very
sensitive instruments so i don't
i try not to bludgeon it too often but
for me yerba mate is absolutely
my favorite stimulant and you know the
argentines will say that there's mataina
which is different from caffeine
i don't think that's true
but my understanding is that mate has
not just caffeine but also theo bromine
as found in dark chocolate and
theophylline as found in green tea so
you get the pharmacokinetics of it
are very very interesting in the sense
that you don't just
get this one peak and then tail you get
seemingly at least three peaks and tails
which for me
allows me to write for several hours
whereas in contrast drinking a cup of
coffee and i love coffee
but i will i'm a fast metabolizer and i
will have this
very rapid peak within maybe 20 25
minutes and then i'll feel tired
and i think it's worth mentioning that
there is also
an amazing ritual around drinking mate
yes
obliges you to share your mate and
really creates kinship brotherhood
sisterhoods
it's important to our cultures yeah
and also also sidenote at least in
argentina at the time
there was a line you could ask someone
if they wanted to you know
is mate i'm forgetting is it masculine
or feminine
so you could ask if somebody asked you
if they want if you wanted to you know
to take
a mate in their apartment that was like
hey come upstairs for a drink kind of
thing
so yeah it's a very deep culture of mate
with the gauchos and everything i mean
it's
uh and it's and it's different in you go
to argentina if you go to uruguay it's
slightly different
the gorgeous the gourds are different
too so i'm drinking
this is a uruguayan maddie that has a
wide mouth
yeah wow it brings back the memories
really brings back there so
you mentioned i think
two species was it two species what is
the other
so the second species is called
cortinarius
chlorosplendidus chloro is green
and splendidus is splendid it's a
beautiful green
mushroom that has a great story to it
i have not only found new species to
science but i found
some new species to chile
and there is a
way of finding them that's quite amusing
to many
and this is how i found cortinarius
chlorosplendidus and of course you know
you're in the forest
you're hiking with you know mycologists
and you
have to go have a pee of course when
nature calls and you
go behind a tree and there you go
you're there you know you're like oh
look there's a green
tree and oh it's new to science
and so i found cortinarius clara
splendidis while
taking the pee break in the forest with
her
with my mycologist from kew gardens to
le niskanen
so i'm like tula wait for me i'll be
right back and then i'm coming back i'm
like tula look this is
a green mushroom it's like but where did
you find i said i was having a pbr in
the tree and it was there
so do you do you have colleagues who
have spent like decades going on the
expeditions to find new species and
they're like
god damn it juliana what next she's
gonna go to find a sandwich
and look behind you know the hot dog
vendor and find a new species
i can't imagine yeah or maybe you're
just a good luck charm they
they they they keep with them
you drink enough money you have to stop
you have to stop and pee and it
definitely sharpens your visual senses
uh where is kew gardens that's kew
yeah kew q gardens it's a royal botanic
garden
in england in richmond and it
houses the world's largest fungarium
the largest collection of dried fungi in
the world
and it has the largest collection of
holotypes
which are the actual physical dried
mushroom from which a species was
described
so amanita galactica has a holotype
which is the exact mushroom i got out
the car
to to feel when i first encountered and
to collect
and so q is very important in mycology
holo type like h-o-l-o like
wholeness wholeness yeah like holistic
holotropic holotype
you can split a holotype to form an
isotype which is
part of that hollow type ah
so the the iso type would be
like taking an arm or a leg off of a
human
is that yes yeah it's like taking
this brings us to something really
interesting and and it's the fact that
the mushroom
isn't the entire fungus
right now we're all talking a lot about
mycelium
lately right and so mycelium would be
like the body
if we do a parallel with a tree the
mycelium is the tree
and the mushroom is like the apple of
the apple tree
right so when we see mushrooms on the
first floor
we may be seeing 20 mushrooms
spread out but they may be from one same
individual one mycelium
so it might be like seeing 20 apples it
comes from one tree
the problem is we don't we never see the
tree so if we
walk into a forest and it's full of
amanita muscadia now this red mushroom
with white dots
we have no way of knowing how many
individuals
are there right it might be one
individual and that's why
we know that the largest living organism
on earth
is a fungus it's the humongous fungus
that's in
oregon it's one mycelium
one genetic body
that covers 900 acres
and produces thousands of mushrooms
every year
right but it's one mycelium that's also
true i want to say i don't know if the
location is
colorado but for certain aspen groves
i want to say are also one gigantic
biomass
yes that's absolutely right it's so
incredible to try to wrap your head
around
yeah question for you as we think about
or just hold as a bookmark this
description of
the mushrooms being the apples on the
tree
the fruiting bodies okay so
so various animals are attracted to
fruits
they eat these fruits they spread the
seeds they help propagate
the lives of these these species right
so
we are symbians in that way
how would you explain why mushrooms
as fruiting bodies the equivalent of
apples
might have hallucinogenic properties
since if we look at say serotonin it's a
very old neurotransmitter
and the serotonin receptors are
very old and so you'd certainly
many animals if not all i don't know
above my pay grade but would would
experience some of these hallucinogenic
effects like the
reindeer in lapland who eat
amanita and so on how do you explain
that
is it well i'm not even going to hazard
a guess i would just love to know
because there are people
who have hypothesized or speculated
that the hallucinogenic effects of some
plants are
a basically an insecticide or a
pesticide
but that that seems to contradict the
purpose of a fruiting body
putting aside or maybe not putting aside
also there are many many
fungi that are extremely toxic if
ingested
but how should one think about the the
analogy of the apple and the mushroom
and factor in the fact that you have
hallucinogenic
mushrooms you have poisonous mushrooms
and so on
one thing that we're learning and at the
fungi foundation
we are participating in a phylogenomic
study
of the genus cylosophy with the natural
history museum of utah
and what we're learning so we're not
looking at
the hallucinogenic compounds
and the chemistry of the fungi in detail
we're looking at the whole genus so if
we
if we look at the genus cylosophy we are
discovering because this is all very new
research we are discovering
that it's very old that it precedes
humanity that it originates
most probably in africa
over 25 million years ago and
that it has radiated across the world
because of animal vectors because
plants have moved as well now the
relationship of a species with a
compound
isn't necessarily direct there is
cylosuby in species that aren't
sorry there is psilocybin in species
that aren't cylosube there is psilocybin
in general like inosity gymnopolis
and others so the relationship
of how a species is
or and a genus is propagated even if it
houses these
compounds doesn't tell the story by
itself
so these compounds are found in other
genera
as well that have the same mechanism of
propagation so it's not that simple to
talk
just about you know that one genus
housing
the species we know that some of these
hallucinogenic
compounds are related to
reactions that have nothing to do with
propagation
there's no evidence of a direct
relationship to
inhibit ingestion from an animal animals
eat
cylosuby containing psilocybin
and propagate them and it doesn't seem
to be something that deters them
do you think it's something that
attracts them i mean there are certain
animals do seem to i mean they seem to
homo sapiens are really attracted yeah
yeah
yeah yeah for sure for sure just for
so we can cover our bases here with sort
of taxonomy 101 since this is not an
area i know much about but you mentioned
genera
can you just walk us through
the basics of what that stack looks like
please
so humans have convened to
name species in a binomial
system so two names and this was coined
by
linnaeus by carl linnaeus and we still
use that system in which we
call a species with a first name
which is the genus and the second name
which is the specific name
so the genus cylosophy and the species
cylosube cubensis for example and that
binomial those two names compose the way
we talk about
all species on earth and we can go
back up that system it's the taxonomical
system
and that's how we get to a kingdom so we
talk about kingdom of the fungi kingdom
of animals kingdom
of plants and we break that down
based on shared characteristics
and finally ultimately get to the
species
name composed of genera and species
what is uh between kingdom
and then species well let's talk about
fungi so because we have kingdom of the
fungi
then we have phyla the filer
in the case of plants we talk about
division
not phyla but animals and fungi talk
about phyla
then class order family
genus species
yeah i need to i need to brush up
it's a language it's a language language
matters
but it's a language in itself and it's a
language that
not everybody should have to speak
because it's a language that you can
learn
now when you talk about the world's
largest fungarium
kew gardens and you mentioned the
holotype if i'm remembering correctly
yeah is a holotype different from
what is the term it just shot out of my
head hold on one second
is is a holotype the same as a voucher
specimen
for plants or is it different a holotype
is the first voucher
it's the voucher from which the species
was described
it's the physical specimen that was the
first
to give the name to a species i see it's
the for the first field sample
it's the first one it's the one that was
used to give the name
and then you can vouch for many more of
the species and deposit them in a
fungarium
so for example i'm curator of the ffcl
fungarium we
house over 2000 specimens vouchers
but we only have i think three holotypes
let's talk about jane goodall she's a
friend and supporter
of yours and she's also been on the
podcast
tremendous woman of course incredible
human being
how did she come into your life oh jane
goodall
visited chile and i was invited to a
dinner
a small dinner that was held to welcome
her and
i took her my books as a gift i think it
was actually only one book i had
published at that moment
and i greeted her listening to her in
awe of this tremendous force of nature
and when i gave her the books
she she said you know this incredible
you know the fungi you you're absolutely
right we
they're they're different from plants
and animals and and
i i'm trying to make a point of
acknowledging them as who they are and
it was it was a very
simple conversation but the next day i
went to one of her talks again and she
came up to me and she said
juliana you know i've been thinking and
i've been looking at your work in your
book and you know
you are where i you are with fungi where
i once was with the chimps
don't stop she said don't
stop i'll never forget her words you
know this feeling of
being a voice for the voiceless
she was at the beginning of her career a
voice for chimpanzees when nobody was
talking for them
or about them and what she had seen
from from that first encounter with me
to the next day where
we met again she had found out that i
was
working to voice for fungal justice you
know justice for the fungi
and she acknowledged that and that was
the first encounter and about
a month later i received a handwritten
letter
from jane to my home in the post
that said how much she had you know
loved meeting me how much she had been
thinking about it and for me to please
excuse her
because she had just written a book and
she hadn't been in time to deliberately
include the fungi
so it's still only referred to plants
and animals and that she was sorry and
that she would make sure
in her next book to acknowledge the
fungi
of course i have that better very well
yeah
that was my story with her and then and
then over time
because of her support and her
encouragement to not
stop on my mission there was something
very acute in that
bonding and that looking at each other
you know we're both field
scientists both mothers and being
a mother field scientist
takes some extra energy let's put it
that way
you know in her case she had put her son
you know in a cage to protect him
from harm i've had to leave my son
you know for a long time to go on
expeditions and and
and it takes that a higher understanding
of your
determination and we we saw that in each
other
she saw it in me and she acknowledged
that and so she's been fundamental and
from then on has supported
with reviews for for books i've
published afterwards and with
endorsing the proposal to include
fungi in language in in conservation
frameworks
she's amazing she is amazing and
and i am going to ask you in a moment
about the
chilean constitution which is going to
seem like a non-sequitur to people who
don't know what i'm talking about we'll
we'll get there
before we do get there i've only met
jane via
zoom or via teleconference
and she has a
uniquely powerful presence even on a
screen
what is it like could you describe what
it is like to spend time
with her or to meet her in person
okay so i'm italian right so she's like
she's like a mother
she's like a mother she she is sensorial
she hugs you she will touch you she will
greet you
and because i'm also british it's
uncharacteristic of brits
she's very physical which is amazing and
she's very easy to reach
i think what jane has that
is of course something to admire and
something i strive to achieve is
really really leaving yourself
out of the picture and focusing on
what your mission is for these organisms
that you dedicate your life to
so how did you get fungi recognized in
the chilean constitution and why is that
meaningful
why is that a mission worth dedicating
yourself to
they're recognized in a constitutional
law so
it's not the actual text of the
constitution it's
the law that is called the general law
for the basis of the environment so it's
the highest
legislative level and
really there's an mo there's a modus
operandi
on how to work for policy change
i learned that way of working while
working in
i worked in oceana chilean office of
the us organization oceana and i worked
in a chilean foundation
called the ram foundation and i was
working
around issues related to the negative
environmental impacts of salmon farming
and so i learned a way of
getting environmental issues
recognized in regulation and legislation
and in 2010 there was an opening
to modify the chilean law and
when a law is open to comment anything
can happen
and that's why legislators are so
reticent to even you know modifying
a small word in in legislation or
regulation because it opens
the opportunity for a lot more to change
and when that happened in 2010 i
started driving the issue that
fungi needed to be recognized on power
as plants and animals
and so that really we cannot talk about
an
ecosystem if we don't acknowledge the
fungi
a lot of international agencies had been
pushing
the world to adopt an ecosystemic view
of nature
now what is an ecosystemic view of
nature it basically
is the fact that nothing is independent
from another that everything is
connected
the organisms that connect everything
are the fungi
if we look at a forest it's like
you know the plants the animals they
don't connect unless the fungi are there
the fungi are like the egg in a cake if
you're going to make a cake
and you have flour and you have sugar
and you have butter if you don't put egg
in it
those ingredients don't stick together
and you can't make the cake
right and the fungi are that like that
egg if they're not in the mix
all these ingredients and components
don't stick together so we went forward
to congress with a group of ngos
and made the case using fungi's
astonishing
attributes and charismatic data and said
chile has been is a country that has a
poor environmental performance
there's international recommendation
from different
agencies to adopt an ecosystemic view of
nature
the only way to do that is to recognize
the fungi
we're a country that houses the first
ngo on earth the first non-profit on
earth that works for the fungi so there
was somebody pushing
with the know-how of the environmental
sector
and after two years two years tim
of talking to senators talking to
members of parliament producing briefs
that
really made the case of why this was
important how it would be done
chile became the first country in the
world to recognize fungi in its law
and then its regulations so honestly the
country has an ecosystemic view of
nature
it doesn't look at plants and animals
are separate from each other
it considers the organisms that unites
it all
what are your hopes for the
implications or consequences of that
where do you hope it to go
might be a better way to put it i'm
happy to see that
it's going towards global recognition
of fungi in policy
on an international level today i am
very proud to say
that large conservation bodies
have adopted mycologically inclusive
language in how they communicate nature
so rewild the organization that was
co-founded by leo dicaprio in a rebrand
it had
from global wildlife conservation has
adopted
the use of fungi in its language
acknowledgement of fungi in its language
the iucn the international union for the
conservation of nature
is talking about plants
animals and fungi and flora fauna and
fanga they are acknowledging the
existence of
the kingdom of the fungi in policy and
regulations and legislation
recommendations
and so my hope is that
we leave the obsolete term of fauna and
flora behind
that we start talking about fauna flora
and funga
funga is the word that delimits fungal
diversity of a given place
that we stop talking about animals and
plants
as macroscopic life on earth only that
we talk about animals fungi and plants
because language creates reality and if
we are still
constantly discarding their existence
through language or not acknowledging
their existence in their role in
language
we will never be able to create funding
streams for their research
we will never be able to create policy
for their inclusion in education
we will never be able to really create
the pipelines and the systems by which
the nature-based solutions that fungi
hold
can be brought to light
my hope for the future is that in at
least my lifetime's effort
people will acknowledge in language
their importance and their existence and
that they will be considered
in policy for education and conservation
[Music]
everywhere it's so important to
underscore what you said about language
creating reality and if you want to
affect change
in policy or regulation the language
that is used
is so important and the labels we use
sort of determine what we see and don't
see i can't remember i think it was
either wittgenstein or gupta who said
the limits of my language are the limits
of my world
and yes i think that's very
very very true let me ask you
if we step back for a second to come
back to
an earlier comment if
fungi and animals have this common
ancestor this kind of fork in the road
that might be represented by this
posterior flagellum
and so on what are the if there
are any implications of that or if we
think about
fungi being closer to animals
or humans than to plants if that's a
defensible statement
what does that mean does it mean more
than
just the sort of academic understanding
or agreement that there is this common
ancestor what does that represent or
mean to you
i mean for for people listening i would
imagine that's kind of a question that
comes to mind
it means a lot first of all it's a fact
we are more closely related to fungi
than fungi to plants so fungi
really are more closely related to
animals
it's hugely important because
if we look at for example i'm going to
use an example penicillin
penicillin is an antibiotic that has
changed
the fate of humanity
because let's convene that before
the first world war you could have died
from an infection from a paper cut
and it's thanks to penicillin and these
antibiotics especially penicillin
that we can cure infections now
penicillin is a
an antibiotic produced by fungi
to protect themselves from bacteria
now the fact that we're so closely
related to fungi
implies that it works for us
too that's wild i've never heard anyone
put it that way
it works for us too we have
the sensitivity to be able to use it
because we
defend ourselves from infection the same
way
that fungi do and it's because we're
related
wow so that's a huge implication and
that's probably the best way the most
graphic way to
say it so if we were to make a
list of reasons or give a few reasons
why it's important
to protect fungi i would love to
hear your take i mean one that comes to
mind which you
alluded to earlier with a comment about
touching the mushroom or picking up the
mushroom and seeing if any animals come
out so you could have worms
insects come out of a mushroom in which
case
if you lose a species this is your
wording so i don't want to
make make any claim to this wording but
if you lose a species you're not just
losing individual you're losing an
ecosystem
right so there's that there is the fact
that
given our sort of shared
origins or biological overlap something
like penicillin
and future discoveries could be made
that could have enormous medical or
therapeutic implications
for humans what are some other reasons
why it is important to pay attention to
this and part of the reason i bring it
up is that
with deforestation or
replacement of biodiverse
forests with say pine farms and things
of this type
you can dramatically reduce dramatically
dramatically reduce whatever it is you
know 50 100 folds reduce
the biodiversity of fungi in a given
area why is it important
to preserve fungi to really pay
attention to this what are some other
reasons
plants can't live out of water without
fungi that
live on or in their roots so
we can go as essential as
the fact that without the fungi life on
earth wouldn't be as we know it
plants trees are
incapable of
living in soil without their symbiotic
fungi they can't synthesize the
nutrients of the soil by themselves
herbivores can't break down the
cellulose cell wall
of the grass they eat or the plants they
eat without the fungi in their gut
that do it for them so we know that
energy is not lost energy is transformed
the organisms that transform energy and
nature
are the decomposers the fungi the
bacteria
without the fungi nothing would
decompose
nothing would regenerate because nothing
would degenerate
and so fungi are essential to life on
earth as we know it
in terms of symbiosis
helping plants and animals live
and in terms of decomposing
which is really the start of the life
cycle depending on i mean it's arguable
here you know
depending on where you stand in a cycle
is where that cycle begins
for mycologists the cycle begins when
things
start to rot the death of
a life form isn't the end of life
it's the beginning of other life forms
and that's what fungi teach you that
the process of decomposition and rotting
is the start of a cycle and the start of
the creation of the
conditions for life to compose
so ultimately
without the fungi plants couldn't live
out of water
nothing would decompose animals wouldn't
be able to
nourish themselves from plants and in
terms of
humanity nothing would ferment
and therefore we wouldn't be able to
preserve anything
and so many fundamental
food and medicine functions
wouldn't be available without the fungi
fungi are essential to life as we know
it we cannot live without them there is
no
life without them on earth
so why don't you tell us more about the
fungi foundation
what is the charter the objective or the
mission or all the above of the fungi
foundation
oh the fungi foundation is the
mycological platform that i founded
to ensure that anybody who
wants to know more about fungi wants to
work for the fungi
has a place to go to and find an answer
which is what i didn't have when i
started
it's an organization that was born in
chile founded here in chile
that has had important policy success
that
has now opened in the us
we are a global organization we're 501c3
in the united states of america we are
an organization that enables people to
understand the wonder and
the awe of kingdom of the fungi
and we are extremely ambitious in what
we want to
achieve as durable change
we have five overarching programs
one is the expeditions program in which
we go to places where nobody's ever been
before to see what fungi there are
the last wild places on earth those
habitats you were talking about that are
being
destroyed at rates that we've never seen
before
on earth because fungi have so many of
these nature-based solutions
like medicine food textiles
we want to document those species before
they're lost forever
and tied to that we have a conservation
program
that takes action for them not to be
lost forever
so we work in the proposal of public
policy
for their protection we work to
assess their threat of extinction
through red listing what is red listing
red listing
is estimating the probability of
extinction of a fungus
or a species so not only
animals and plants can go extinct fungi
can ii
and the process of red listing
determines
how close or how far we are to
extinction for a species
so through the tool of red listing we
can
make the case of policies and management
plans to protect those species in those
last wild places
we also have an elders program
which is it's a line of work that
is very dear to me as his expeditions
and what we've taken on is to map
every known ancestral and traditional
use of fungi by humanity
and that map is very well advanced
we have collected both
published information and oral history
from different parts of the world that
talk of how humanity has culturally
co-evolved with fungi
to weave baskets to make sunblock
to dye fibers to
be used as symbols of power to treat
infertility
to treat wounds and so that program
really is a reservoir it's like the
noah's
ark of fungal solutions for the world
and it's a huge responsibility we have
it's never been done before
and last but not least i would say
our work in education we believe that
in schools around the world children
should be taught as much
about fungi as they are taught about
plants and animals
and to do that fungi have to be included
in
school curriculum we have developed
a curriculum and we have co-created
part of that curriculum with fantastic
fungi and
i'm happy to say that the fungi
foundation will be
implementing a school curriculum paired
to
u.s standards we'll be implementing in
the us and in other parts of the world
so that children can learn
about fungi in school now that's a huge
task but if you think about it tim
50 years ago when people studied in
school
and they studied the cell nobody knew
that the cell had
you know a mitochondria a mitochondria
which is this you know structure inside
a cell that has its own dna it has its
own information
you know my mother didn't study the cell
with the mitochondria
today you wouldn't think about teaching
the cell without teaching about the
mitochondria my hope
is that in 30 years 40 years you would
never dare
teach about um nature
without fungi having their own explicit
modules and curriculum so we're building
that
so those are some of the things we're
doing the organization is blessed to
have paul stamets on its board
to have natalie kelly on its board
joanna foster who is a winemaker in
argentina in other places
with amazing natural wines and
antonio basiiga lupo and jose mingo who
are founding members
so we're a pioneering organization
and we've been faced with the challenge
of bringing
justice to fungi through formal
inclusion and all
everything i've mentioned but at the
same time of being trailblazers and
trying to find a way for this to happen
for the fungi
and people can learn more
at fungi.org is that right
all right wonderful and we will mention
that again i will mention that again
and we will also include it in the show
notes what
other sources of inspiration and
knowledge
have greatly influenced you
let's start with books are there any any
particular books
that have greatly influenced you with
respect to
mushrooms mycology fungi nature
and are there any books that you would
most
recommend to others perhaps they're the
same perhaps they're different
books that have greatly inspired me
recently
is merlin sheldrate's book entangled
life i love it i've read it several
times
entangled life is a must read if i look
back
there are different titles of chilean
authors
that have really inspired me luis
sepulveda
has written some some amazing books that
short stories but that really talk about
the complexity of of life and the
simplicity also
with which you can face complexity i
love that
yeah i have drawn inspiration from
authors like luis sepulveda who
even if you read deep into complex
authors like you know
milan kundera or you know others
you can always from these huge
complexities
find simplicity and that's been i think
what has inspired me from everything i
read is
finding simplicity from complexities i
would say that
authors like gabriela mistral
have been important galeano eduardo
galliano an important
also a very important author so a lot of
latin american
books really into that i just pulled up
luis and it seems like
quite a bit of his work has also
been translated and in addition to
spanish he speaks english french and
italian or
bespoke i should say passed away in 2020
and in the in the late 80s he conquered
the literary scene this is from
wikipedia i'm impressed with the wording
with his first novel the old man who
read love novels so very well known
and i would definitely recommend one of
his titles
which i will translate directly from the
spanish
but it's the story of a seagull
and of the cat that taught it to fly
yeah there it is i highly recommend that
book
it's very short and then another one of
his titles that is extraordinary
is the world of the end of the world and
it talks about the southern cone
but it really there is a lot of beauty
and
and a lot of life learning in his
novels that can take complexities and
and show you sometimes how simple
something complex can be
the world at the end of the world that's
from 1989 mundo delfin del mundo
sounds so good in spanish and then the
story of a seagull and the cat who
taught her to fly in
that's 1996 fantastic book which seems
like it was originally published
in portuguese i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna hazard
to try to pronounce that i'll get 40
of it right yeah in your own life
or looking forward it could be related
to your mission it could be in life in
general
can you think of any examples of facing
complexity
with simplicity or finding the elegant
or
simple way to look at or contend
with something that appears complex
absolutely i mean
positioning yourself you know as a 19
year old 20 year old
faced with an overwhelming fungal
passion
fungal duty and inaudible responsibility
towards the kingdom of the fungi in a
world where
they are associated to rot to death to
paganism
founding you know the world's first ngo
in a world where
absolutely no funding existed at all
and still hardly exists for anything
fungal in terms of
policy now we're talking about before
the film fantastic fungi before
cylosubi was recognized as medicine in
the western world
that is the most complex scenario i've
ever been faced with
and in that huge complexity
and adversity i found
the simplicity of belief in yourself
first thing i mean it couldn't be
that this thing that just wouldn't stop
him would only grow inside me and this
vision that i could see possible
it couldn't be that it didn't exist and
so
as complex and as adverse as
the environment was the simple
looking inside and
giving yourself permission to try
and to do it has been
the most fundamental thing and it still
is that way we are still
you know when you talk to people and you
say you know i work
for mushrooms and i work looking for
mushrooms protecting mushrooms making
sure that everybody knows about
mushrooms
most people look you think what are you
doing you know why
why would you do that i mean how can you
live
like that how can you feed your son
from doing that you know and the answer
is inside
and the answer is in hard work so that's
what i've learned
from complexity simplicity of looking in
i certainly hope you're right that in
maybe not 30 maybe 20 maybe 10 years
that people will look back
and the answer will be very
obvious as to why you would dedicate
yourself to
fungi in the same way that if someone
were to say today i dedicate myself
to plants in xyz capacity or i dedicate
myself to
preservation and conservation of animals
in xyz capacity
they would not have that surprised
response
yeah and yes if you look at the
importance
of fungi mycelium
mushrooms as not just the egg
in the cake i think as you put it the
connective tissue that
binds plants and animals together but
also as close
cousins of ours from which
so many discoveries are waiting to be
found or within which
so many discoveries are waiting to be
found i think it's it's a real
imperative to to study but you can only
study that which you preserve
in a sense and it's incredibly important
it's incredibly important i think also
tim in this hyper-connected world
i have learned and i'm very grateful to
be of a generation that
wasn't as hyper connected in our teens
i have learned that it's important
to be more with yourself than with
others all day i mean i see people today
constantly looking at what others are
doing and
constantly looking and trying to reflect
themselves in
in what others choose to share and
how important it is when you believe in
something when you have an idea
to take the time with yourself to
develop it
to investigate what you're thinking
about we all
can make a contribution if we give
ourselves the time and space
to develop our contribution and not be
constantly looking for
everybody else's contribution in a way
so this hyper connectivity i think is
not
helping us to be able to take on these
paths of
in-depth you know study results aren't
always immediate
you know it takes a long time and it's
okay for it to take a long time
you don't present an idea and then the
next day have a result
it takes a long time it takes hard work
and you can't do that if you're
constantly looking
at everybody else's life yeah agreed
if i can't remember the attribution but
if if music is the space between the
notes
in some respects you know thinking and
discovery are
the spaces between the interactions
sometimes
yeah and if the density is such that
you're saturated with communication
saturated with stimulation there just
isn't the space
for that germination yeah and
i'm gonna make an awkward segue
but i have to ask you before we go
because i've heard so much about
the teleride mushroom festival and i've
never been
i have friends who have spent lots of
time
in telluride and love telluride quite in
and of itself
i've also never been to telluride and
you will be going there very soon i
think
in mid-august or mid to late august
august 19th
something like that yes i will be giving
a keynote
on august 19th yeah can you describe the
telly ride mushroom festival
what it is why it's interesting and also
what you'll be
presenting on what you'll be doing your
keynote about telluride mushroom
festival is a must
tim you have to go to the telluride
mushroom festival
it is a safe place to express
fungal love and adoration that's one
thing i have to say
it's the oldest festival in the u.s
dedicated to fungi
it's in its 41st edition it was founded
by four extraordinary men
paul stamets andy whale
emmanuel salzburg and gary linkov
now this festival was the first place
in the u.s where people could get
together and talk about
psychedelics and entheogens and
it has had some of the world's most
renowned mycologists talking about the
science of these species
it has the world's most renowned
psychiatrist talking about the
psychedelic renaissance and even before
the renaissance
let's face it you know it's been a house
to talk about to research to
think about and to celebrate psychedelic
mushrooms and
anything mushroom in general i have had
the honor
of participating for about six years now
so a very small portion of its existence
and my first feeling there was
there are more of us that was the first
thing i'm not the only one i'm not the
only one you know i found my tribe there
and for the last five years i've had the
honor of moderating the final panel
with important people talking and
thinking about
fungi and psychedelic fungi like dennis
mckenna
dave nichols and many others where we
can sit down
and have a candid conversation and talk
about things nobody really wants to talk
about
in a scientific paper and that maybe
they won't say in a press
in the press so it's a very safe and
candid space
to talk and to ask about psychedelics
and really anything
fungal there's a lot of you know cooking
with fungi
a lot of foraging information about
foraging there's a lot of
practical you know workshops on how to
cultivate or decompose you know toxic
substances with fungi
so it's an extraordinary space this year
paul stamets will also be
going and giving a keynote so it's a
great year
just saying and my keynote will be
on our global
policy work for conservation frameworks
so
the fungi foundation is known for making
change
political change in chile but we have
now
taken that to the world and we
have had some important international
policy wins that i will be presenting
and showing at the festival that is very
exciting
congratulations thank you
just a few more questions dame of the
order of the star i did not look this up
deliberately someone to ask you about it
that is the coolest title
i think i've ever heard in my life what
is
what does it mean to be a dame of the
order of the star okay
so the order of this stuff first of all
is you know i was
how how do i say i was honored with the
title of being
dame of italy and there are
different orders of damehood so the
order of the star
is a house of
celebrated italian citizens that weren't
born on italian soil
so if i were born on italian soil i
wouldn't be part of the order of the
star
so the order of the star is exclusive to
italians who have made a contribution to
the country
from somewhere else and i was
named dame of the order of the star of
italy
because of my work in mycology and for
the fungi
and i really i'm so sad that business
cards are no longer really a thing
because
if you print new business cards
if that ever happens maybe there's still
a thing in some places i really hope
that that is somewhere
on that business card it is just
spectacular
juliana juliana forty
fourteen with the trill yeah f-u-r-c-i
i'm so impressed by you and the work
that you do
and i would like to heavily
encourage people to go to fungi.org
and i would like to also
contribute to your work in a small way
i'd like to donate
fifty thousand dollars from my
foundation to
your foundation to the fungi foundation
and i would like to encourage other
people to take a look
at the work take a close look at the
work that you do
and consider supporting it i think what
you're doing is very important
and i'll say the website one more time
because i would really encourage people
to take a look
you've been very dedicated you've taken
the true and the hard path you've made a
lot of sacrifices
i know it hasn't been easy you've been
incredibly
strong and like you said you've had
winds
and the fungi foundation is pursuing an
important mission so
i'm very excited to support
with my own foundation and i encourage
people to take a look and consider doing
the same
thank you very much tim thank you very
much on behalf of
the team and the board that's emotion
coming through the microphone which
isn't um thank you very much we've we've
never had
support like that before thank you very
very much
i hope to make you proud
and we will make durable change for the
fungi
and uh and someday we'll have to share
some mate together
and if hopefully and tell you right
that's right that's right so if i make
it to telluride
and i also would encourage people to
check out the festival
and to to hear your keynote in person i
have heard tremendous things about the
festival
i mean tremendous 10 out of 10
recommendations from
multiple people i deeply respect and
also multiple friends who know me really
well
so it's really it's really just a matter
of time before i get there myself
i have to say that this year for those
listening
paul stamets is also known as pablo so
pablo doesn't go every year he doesn't
go every year he's going this year
and it's going to be an extraordinary
festival
he is going to be giving a keynote as
well and
i encourage you to consider popping in
it's not very long it's a few days and
the community that exists there is
extraordinary and the opportunity to
talk to people who are trailblazing
thinking and debating and creation
around access to use of psychedelic
medicine
through access to cultivating your own
foods and medicines
through access to foraging and access to
talking to people who are dedicating
their lives to bringing
justice to the fungi i highly recommend
it and this no year is better than this
year
all right well i'm gonna have to take a
close look at my calendar in that case
and julian is there anything else you
would like to say
any content
thank you very much you know we're not
we're not used to any
help so thank you i'm just saying
give me a moment i can't continue that
nothing's happened
take a minute no problem thank you so
much
it's only been you know 10 years trying
trying to never you know our
our um our work is um
thank you i don't know i don't there's
nothing to say but i don't want to
explain anything i just want to say
thank you and i wish i could give you a
hug and give you some i wouldn't give
you this mate lavado i would make you a
new monkey
let me gather myself
can i just add also when i received your
email
saying that you had seen some of the
some of the videos i was like oh
[ __ ] i wonder what he's seen
and then i i actually misleadingly
thought oh let me think of what's
been done in english and now i know that
you might have seen what was in spanish
so
now even where i was like oh no what is
he saying
well i was impressed and not turned away
i was not discouraged in any way and i'm
so happy that
we were able to connect and to do this
and
have really learned so much i have tons
of notes tons of things to follow up on
i'm going to check out
luis okay so your question your question
no my question is not a mandatory
question
it's just it's very simple is there
anything else you would like to
say before we wrap up any request of the
audience
anything you'd like to share anything at
all really before we close this
conversation
i would really like to invite people to
think about how important it is to let
things rot
and that it's really not about
rock and roll anymore it's about rotten
mold
and we have to let things rot
you know rotten mold baby all all the
time
if we don't let things rot then
cycles don't start don't flow
we can't fix carbon we can't decompose
to be able to recompose we can't
degenerate to be able to regenerate
i would really like to invite people to
think about
how even the most glorious moment of an
old tree's life is when that tree falls
to the ground
and starts decomposing and turns back
into soil
let's not be afraid about decomposition
and there's a lot of hype around
regeneration and that can't happen if
things don't rot
got to let it rot gotta look right let
it
one more question we gave a few or you
gave a few book recommendations and
tangled life and
and other novels and so on
if someone wanted to
take their first steps into learning
more about
fungi yeah about
could be mushrooms i mean pick your term
are there one or two books that you
might suggest
people take a look at i suggest a film
and then a book
so watch fantastic fungi and then read
entangled life
and another maybe another fun
really fun way is to read the triumph of
the fungi
by nicholas p money
now nick money has several books about
fungi there's a book called the rise of
the yeast
as well and it's about the story of how
yeast has shaped humanity
so nicholas p money is a must read
to learn in a lighter way in a less
scientific way
but in a really well informed and
referenced and
real way about how how fungi have shaped
the planet beautiful and may they
continue
to support and shape
the planet and hopefully with our help
and
in part vis-a-vis the fungi foundation
and people can find the fungi foundation
at fungi.org
you can find giuliana fortui i love just
i'm trying to get it right
at julie fungi
g-i-u-l-i-f-u-n-g-i
also at fungi foundation on instagram
and we will include links to everything
we discussed
in addition to all of that at tim.blog
forward slash
podcast and what a tremendous pleasure
and hope to see you
in person meet you in person very soon
indeed thank you for taking the time
thank you very much
and thank you very much for the space
absolutely my pleasure
and to everyone
listening let things rot learn more
about fungi
your close cousins and until next time
thank you for tuning in hey guys this is
tim again just a few more things before
you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
fourhourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep
my god am i in love with ate sleep good
sleep is the ultimate
game changer more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back on and repeating ad nauseam
but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever
why because i'm using a simple device
called the pod
pro cover by eight sleep it's the
easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about
the best tools for sleep enhancing sleep
and ate sleep was by far and away the
crowd favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress and
start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need cooling she loves the heat
and we can have our own bespoke
temperatures
on either side which is exactly what
we're doing now for me
and for many people the result eight
sleep users fall asleep up to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40
and get more restful sleep overall i can
personally attest to this because i
track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling refreshed and now my dear
listeners that's you guys
you can get 250 off of the pod pro cover
that's a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim or use code
tim that's eight all spelled out
e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code tim tiff eight sleep dot com
slash tim for 250 off
your pod pro cover this episode is
brought to you by
mac weldon mag weldon is reinventing
men's
basics they believe in smart design
premium fabrics and
simple shopping i've been smashing and
testing
the hell out of a bunch of their stuff
and i'm gonna focus on their underwear
as one example
i've been wearing their air knit x five
inch boxer briefs
for a while now and i absolutely love
them i've used them to hike
in national parks like big bend i use
them to record podcasts
they can be used for anything they are
engineered to keep you dry cool
and comfortable to the end of your
workout or work day the fabric is soft
lightweight microfiber which maximizes
airflow and stretches in every direction
it's breathable
moisture wicking and odor fighting which
is great for a bridge troll
like me here's what a few critics have
to say new york times slash wire cutter
evaluated mac weldon's 18-hour jersey
boxer brief
here we go quote our testers seemed
almost conflicted about how fancy they
felt
while wearing these boxer briefs quote
these are lovely you put them on and you
feel rich
one tester said this underwear makes me
want to waste money on a hotel room and
fancy boost to seduce my already wife
and spoil her right added another
now to esquire quote an expertly
executed pair of briefs from a brand
that doesn't better than almost
anyone else and quote now to men's
health but mack weldon took the process
seriously
with over 10 000 hours to perfect the
best underwear
money can buy seriously this one checks
all the boxes you should be looking for
when purchasing underwear
end quote now back to me mac walden also
covers a lot more
than underwear they have socks shirts
underwear hoodies
polos active shorts they check all the
boxes mack welding promises comfort and
a consistent fit for all of your basics
so check them out and try them out if
you don't like your first pair of
underwear you can actually keep them and
they will still
refund you no questions asked so you
have nothing to lose
again my favorite so far is probably the
air knit x
five inch boxer briefs it seems like the
18 hour
jersey boxer brief is one of the most
popular so check them out
to get 20 off of your first order visit
mackweldon.com
tim tim and enter promo code timtim
that's
m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n.com
tim tim and use promo code tintin
mack weldon reinventing men's basics
you